hi everybody thanks for joining me today
my name is Denise Ozma I'm at animal
program coordinator for Colorado State
University and I'm very happy to be here
doing this presentation today I know you
can't tell from my webcam view but I'm
actually eight months pregnant right now
which means that it would be very
difficult for me to travel to a meeting
to give any kind of presentation so this
is really a very cool opportunity for me
I'm very happy to be here and I want to
thank the program committee for inviting
me to be a part of this so we have a Q&A
box that you guys can use if you have
questions throughout I was told to keep
kind of keep it closed on my end so that
it's not distract me until the end so
whatever questions that you have will
get saved up until I finish with my
presentation and then hopefully we'll
have some time left over at the end for
that so today i am going to be pointing
out some different ways that we can all
satisfy the training requirements that
we have and my primary responsibility at
colorado state university is as a
trainer and we have a pretty diverse
program here so that i'm going to be
pointing out ways that we satisfy
training requirements to accommodate all
of our various situations throughout the
presentation also just want to apologize
in advance i do seem to be getting a
little bit of cold and I will do the
best I can but unfortunately I think my
voice may deteriorate a little bit
throughout the presentation hopefully
that won't be too distracting alright so
as with most everything in our industry
our training program kind of goes back
to and starts with the I cook and how
they choose to execute their massive
responsibility of ensuring that
personnel all have adequate training
before they work with animals I'll talk
a little bit about why record keeping is
such an important part of that and how
will keeping records here and I have
sort of a big laundry list that goes
through and
details are all the different training
requirements that we have and i'll be
running through that starting with those
that i'm going to refer to as the more
basic or simpler to satisfy requirements
and then kind of moving along and any
complexity or specificity so this is
some of the language that's found in our
regulations i'm sure you're all familiar
with already comes straight from the
guide and the Animal Welfare Act
regulations tells the eye to cook that
they need to make sure that staff are
adequately trained but it doesn't really
give very much guidance on how we might
go about accomplishing such a large task
so as an industry that's why it's really
important for us to share and try and
kind of standardized some ideas that's a
spirit of my presentation today I'm a
big fan of big borrowing and stealing
training ideas whenever possible so as
to not reinvent the wheel and so I want
to I want to just share with you some
ideas and and hopefully some of them
might be helpful in your program so
record keeping is tremendously important
as you know when you have inspectors
come in if you can't demonstrate records
of something having happened then as far
as they're concerned it didn't happen
and so the first big question with our
record keeping is going to be paper
versus electronic and if you are capable
of demonstrating your training adequacy
with paper records then by all means I
think you should just stick with it
there's no reason to invest the
resources necessary an electronic system
paper records really were not sufficient
for us just because of our size and the
complexity of our program and so I've
taken the journey over the last few
years from paper to electronic and can
talk a little bit about how we've
accomplished that so I have I did
briefly use a commercially available
program and there's lots of those out
there they can be very very fancy they
can also be very expensive but if the
resources are there to buy a program
that's great if not what we did was we
actually built our own system and I
can't say enough good things about it it
really has helped our program
tremendously it has lots of good points
one is that it's multi department so
there's many different groups of people
that are using the same training
database it enables us to deliver
materials online and also to administer
functionality for in-person classes and
it also does a bunch of administrative
tasks like sending reminders generating
class lists recording participation and
even administering quizzes ping and it's
not very fancy but this is what it looks
like when a student logs in this is sort
of the main interface that they would
see you can see across the top dark gray
bar that's a list of the departments
that are all included and then down
below it lists the training that's
available if someone clicks on one of
the departments such as the Animal Care
and Use then it specifies only the
classes that are specific to that
department so you can see here that we
have for online classes available and if
you have the ability to scroll down
you'll see that we have many many in
person workshops also so from here the
student can click on take now and take
one of the online classes they can
register for an in-person class they can
also see their own training record so
they can see when did they take CPR when
is their bio hazard training due for
renewal what Mouse classes have they
taken it's kind of a one-stop shop for
them which is very handy for
administrators they can log in and see
anybody's training records so that's
really handy for our I cook coordinators
to be able to log on and
see whether someone took the training
that they claim that they have taken and
one other really nice thing that
happened for us when we implemented this
training database is it improved the
visibility of our classes and it
actually kind of advertised our training
program for us so this was developed in
the environmental health and safety
department and they primarily were
focusing on hazardous waste generator
classes and biosafety tech classes at
first and those are required and they're
also required to be repeated annually so
when they shared their program with us
and allowed us to add our classes into
their database what happened was every
time somebody logged in to take their
required training then they could see oh
look at there's all these Mouse classes
available as well and so that was really
a really big benefit for our program in
general so you might be wondering what
did all this cost us seeing as how the
department who developed it is not my
department it actually didn't cost us
anything which is just very fortunate
for our department the department that
did develop it had to have the resources
to dedicate a person to building it and
not only that but once you finish
building it he has to continue to
maintain it and there's quite a bit of
work involved there so it's probably was
you know his full-time job for a period
of time and has decreased down to maybe
ten percent of his effort at this point
alright so let's talk a little bit about
who is conducting the training many many
different people are completely
qualified and excellent trainers and
whatever works for your facility is fine
it definitely makes more sense to have
dedicated training staff if you are a
larger facility and if you have a larger
volume of people who need the same kind
of training and so then the next group
of people there is going to be what
works better usually in smaller maybe
less central
type facilities where it's going to be
supervisors and pis who that's kind of
part of their other duties as assigned
rather than having dedicated training
staff I definitely don't want to suggest
one approach is better than the other at
CSU we're taking an all-of-the-above
kind of approach we do have a
centralized portion of our program and
just to give you an idea of the scope of
it we report around 100,000 rodents per
year and we have one part time dedicated
tryna which is me and that level of
staffing does seem to work very well for
us and having talked with other trainers
at meetings and gatherings it seems to
be pretty comparable to what other
facilities are sized are also doing
during the time when I was creating the
training program and putting all the
pieces in place it was more like a
hundred percent of my job it took up a
lot more time but now that everything's
in place and it's just a matter of
delivering and kind of ongoing
improvement to the program it fits very
well into that fifty percent time frame
of my job we also have a decentralized
portion of our program which consists
mostly of agriculture and wildlife
research and in that instance we have
lots of small groups that each one
operates independently and so in their
case it's the second group of people
that I have mentioned I'm a slide that
are doing the training which works very
well for them particularly because what
they're doing is oftentimes so
specialized that that they need someone
that's an immediate part of their staff
to be conducting the training and of
course we have all had lots of external
resources available to us that I hope
you guys are all taking advantage of we
do use the a last learning library some
and it's just one of several online
modalities that are out there by
training consultants referring not only
to consultant groups that come in and
deliver training but all
so just the kind of informal all the
time I'm emailing somebody to say hey do
you know how to do this and if I have
something really interesting that I need
to learn maybe I'm traveling somewhere
to learn something or bringing someone
in and then of course the the printed
materials kind of goes back to my beg
borrow and steal thing which I can't
tell you how grateful I am when I go out
on the web and find the material it's
already available that I don't have to
recreate for myself hmm so that brings
me to my big laundry list and I
basically just took this straight out of
the guide and Animal Welfare Act
regulations and plopped it on this slide
here I'm going to go through and talk
about each and every one of these and
different ways of satisfying these
requirements we're going to start with
the things that I'm going to call the
training basics so I'm not calling them
basics because I'm trying to suggest
that these are easy topics or that
they're not interesting or not
complicated but I do believe that these
are factual based easy straightforward
to cover materials so that makes them
good for putting into media that's meant
for mass consumption it's also good
because everyone needs the exact same
information so we might have a
researcher that's out bandung birds in
the galapagos islands and we might have
somebody else that's infecting my sand
at a bsl-3 laboratory both of them need
to know the same animal care needs
legislation the same information about
the I cook function and so forth so my
suggestions here classroom-based
computer-based or written through those
are the three modalities that that we
are going to work really well so the
main advantage with computer based
training is that once you've invested
the time that it takes to create the
training and there's very minimal upkeep
type effort after that
excuse me also your researchers have the
opportunity to take that training when
they want to take it and I know that
they appreciate that with their busy
schedules classroom training it's kind
of the opposite you do have a trainer
who has to be in the classroom investing
their time each and every time it's
offered the researchers have to follow
your schedule instead of following their
own schedule however the huge advantage
to classroom training of course over
computer training is going to be the
face time which can be very difficult to
achieve in today's workplace sometimes
we have relationships with people for
years without ever actually meeting them
and so when you when you have a
classroom training that people come to
it gives you some pretty nice
relationship building opportunities and
also gives you a chance to get real time
feedback to the training that's going on
and then written training also a
possibility here i would say probably
the lesser of the three just because of
the fact that there's a certain portion
of people that are never going to read
the materials that you give them so it's
a lot harder to make sure that they
actually actually got the information
that you're trying to deliver so here is
what we do we have a online module
that's delivered through the training
database and in addition to the list
from the required training requirements
and we're also adding in several others
that fit very well with this training
and it is a required training there's a
quiz at the end so the researchers have
to go online and take it take the quiz
before they're allowed to add themselves
to a protocol it has a nice little
checklist over here on this side so if
you're like me and you like to make a
list to check things off when you finish
them then this is a fabulous training
modality because we just checked off
two three four five of our big
requirements with pretty minimal effort
so this particular training took me
about a week to write and then it passed
through a little bunch of different
offices and several different people how
to tweak it and stamp it with approval
so maybe a month total in development so
not a not a huge investment of time up
front but we've had so many people take
this training that we and we don't even
know who all of them are so when you go
online and look at the list of people
who have taken it some of them are like
out in Housing and Dining Services and
and really kind of odd departments that
you wouldn't expect so in addition to
satisfying a training requirement it
also has kind of served a little bit of
an outreach function at our university
which is nice and now i'm going to start
moving on to slightly more specific
topics so occupational health and
safeties the next one on my list and for
some of you this may fit very well into
the the basic training that we just
talked about if you have most of you
people working with similar animals
similar types of hazards for us it's
actually quite specific because we have
people who are working out in the
environment we have people who are
working with all different kinds of
animals and and different kinds of
research and so for our wildlife folks
it's completely appropriate for them to
be trained on how to handle a mountain
lion attack but they really don't need
to be trained on how to avoid a
repetitive motion injury from changing
mouse cages and so if you want your
staff to care about the training and to
be engaged with with what you're telling
them then it's always best to try and
specify things to what really matters
for someone in their actual job and so
in thinking about your occupational
health and safety training you want to
worry about who are you training I have
just selected for
different groups of types of animal
users for example there are other groups
that we deal with that aren't included
here like administrative people who just
because of the proximity of where they
work or being exposed allergens possibly
our facilities maintenance folks and
visitors and and other groups the what
is going to be what specific hazards and
mitigations do they need to learn about
and so for our small animal users for
example allergies is a huge one
ergonomics like I mentioned the
repetitive motion injury is very
important our staff that are working in
a bsl-3 are going to need to know how to
minimize production of aerosols they
need to know how to go to a hospital and
get the correct kind of medical
attention if they're exposed to an
exotic agent large animal users there's
crushing injuries that could potentially
occur they might be working outside so
just being out in the elements might be
one of their occupational hazards and
then our field biologists of course have
to worry about endemic zoonotic diseases
such as hantavirus and then the how
looks very similar to my basic training
list this is also a nice topic to put
into like a mass media kind of modality
if you have the ability to do that and a
couple of other suggestions I have here
one is your protocol forms which we
don't always think about is being
educational but if your P I has to
specify in a protocol form what is the
hazard how are you mitigating hazard and
how are you training your staff how to
be safe doing their work then that's a
pretty good way of showing that they're
trained in occupational health and
safety and also depending on how you use
your risk assessment form and how your
medical providers follow up with people
after they have completed the risk
assessment that is another possibility
for providing training without expending
a lot of
additional effort so our largest group
that has the same occupational health
and safety hazards is our animal care
staff this is what I do for them it's I
have not put it online because there's
not a tremendous amount of turnover so
I'm only training a few people every
several months something like that so
it's just a PowerPoint presentation that
we do in a classroom it does address all
of the hazards that they encounter but I
focused specifically on the ones that
actually cause injuries or actually
caused problems for the staff so
allergies again is really big one and
the repetitive motion injuries are huge
for us and so I have several slides that
just talk about stretching and how often
should you take a break to do the
stretching and what kinds of things you
can do to protect yourself from those
types of injuries alright so now we're
going to move on to even more specific
training which is going to become
technical in nature so lumping all
together the next three requirements
into what I'm going to call animal
handling so that covers basic animal
needs properly handling and euthanasia
and then also I definitely include
whatever common procedures that your
research folks are going to be doing
into this type of training since we're
now talking about hands-on technical
procedures you have to have hands-on
technical training there's no way of
helping a person become confident at a
technical procedure without them
actually physically doing the procedure
but having said that I do think there's
still a place for handouts and for
online type training for animal handling
so I have handouts for every hands-on
class that I do I think they're very
important for adding a layer of
repetition especially after class
over someone wants to go back and review
how something is done and these are a
couple of examples one is from my guinea
pig handout and one is from my mouse
hand out and they just are meant to
demonstrate how I break everything down
step by step and use a lot of big high
quality color photos which i think is
extremely important I know that for me
personally if I'm trying to learn or
perfect or tweak a procedure that I do I
go out on the web and I try and find
pictures of other people doing it and
I'm ever so grateful when I can find
something like that often times that's
all I need to help me figure out
precisely how to do something new excuse
me and the grainy small black-and-white
photos really don't do a whole lot for
me so definitely go looking on the web
you can find a lot of stuff that's
readily available I would like to offer
up any training materials that I have so
if there's anything that I talked about
during the presentation that you think
you might want to have a copy of just
email me later I'd be more than happy to
send it to you and also I I just wanted
to give a shout out to ma tei at this
point which is the laboratory animal
welfare training exchange if you are not
a member and you are involved with
training you should very seriously
consider joining it's really inexpensive
they have a place for members only on
their website where you can go and get
other people's training materials that
are freely sharing that you can take and
use however you need they also have a
meeting every other year which I've
attended three times now and really have
found to be the most beneficial meeting
for me I get the most take away from
that meeting been any other that I
attend so so then back to my slide I
also use an online module
it's only for my mouse class and the
reason is that I have more volume of
people coming through my mouse class
than all of my other training put
together and so I do everything I can
have to make that class that very very
efficient and make it run very smooth
just to try and help with that large
volume of people so the training
database will stop you when you try to
sign up for the mouse class and say you
have to take the online module first and
so then once someone takes that then it
allows them to sign up for the mouse
class so by the time someone comes to my
class I know that they've already had
this preview of what we're going to be
doing and I think it helps in a few
different ways for one it adds a layer
of repetition kind of like I mentioned
with the handouts but in this case it's
in advance so by the time someone has
come to my class and I've given the
demonstration in there at their table
getting ready to pick up a mouse they've
already had the really important
concepts hit on at least twice and I
think that helps people to kind of get
moving and and reinforces ideas another
way that I think it's helpful is for
people who have a language barrier so
our English as a Second Language folks
who may have much better meeting
comprehension than listening
comprehension have had an opportunity to
review the material in written form and
in pictures in the online module before
they come to class and then finally I
like it because it means that there's
not going to be any surprises for people
when they show up to the class this may
not relate to all of you but I have a
lot of undergrad students and a lot of
people who have never had any exposure
to animal research before coming through
and there have been a few instances
where someone came to class and became
upset by what we were doing in class so
with using the prerequisite online
module people already know it looks
I'm happen and they know kind of what it
looks like they know that we're going to
be euthanizing nice at the end of the
class so we don't have any of those
disruptive surprises happening all right
so we already talked about how your
animal handling training is going to be
hands-on so then the next big question
is can you handle just online excuse me
just on demand as needed one-on-one kind
of training or is your program big
enough that you need to implement
regularly occurring wet labs or
workshops it'd be really nice if you
could obtain data about how many people
get added to a mouse protocol every
month that are brand new or that type of
information to help determine whether
there's a big enough demand there and
how often you might need to have classes
probably many of you don't have that
kind of information available i know
that i didn't and so we felt that there
was certainly a need for a regularly
occurring class so the way that we
determined how frequently to offer it
and so forth was pretty much just by
trial and error we we put the class
together and we offered it and just
decided to see what happens so what
happened was it filled with a huge
waitlist and so we repeated it and it
filled with huge wait list and we had
numerous iterations of this which really
kind of pointed out a benefit of having
a regular class over just the on-demand
training which is that there was this
huge backlog of people who wanted to be
trained but we're not coming forward and
asking for the training for whatever
reason and so by just putting it out
there that we're having a class come and
see what we have to offer it brought all
those people out so there's this huge
surge of people and then it was kind of
strange because after that
there was very little demand at all and
we offered the class quarterly and it
never fill and we knew that there was a
need out there but people were not aware
that the training was being offered was
really the problem so we had to put a
lot of effort into advertising and as I
mentioned the training database helped
us with that by increasing the
visibility of our program but we did
flyers and newsletters and emails and
eventually maybe by word of mouth more
than anything the word got out and the
demand started to go up and so it's it's
still going up and mmm so we just kept
offering the classes more frequently and
we've gotten to the point where we're
offering the mouse class once a month
and it usually almost fills I don't
usually have a wait list so that was our
clumsy way of determining how often we
needed to offer class about once a month
seems to work very well I imagine there
will come a time when I'll start having
a waitlist on my once a month classes
and at that time then we'll just start
offering it twice a month so our next
question up here is required or
voluntary and and by this I'm talking
about the I cook of course so some
places will say if you're going to work
with mice you're going to take Mouse
Class A B and C and so that's the
required approach I think one really big
benefit to doing it that way is that you
catch everybody and that you know that
everybody's had the same training on all
the procedures and you don't have to
worry about people falling through the
cracks probably the biggest disadvantage
to that method is but not all the
researchers want or need to take all
that training and that that's
potentially increasing their perception
of administrative burden or undue burden
that they don't have to deal with so on
the other hand you have I cooks who do
not have the required training this is
how
auraiya cook functions and I think it
actually puts more of the burden back on
the committee and less of the burden on
the researchers because they have to
evaluate each person as an individual
and determine based on their training
record yes they're qualified or no
they're not qualified and if they are
not qualified here's how they're
recommending that they that they go
about getting that needed training one
thing that are I cook does a lot is
they'll take a training record and look
through it and say okay we believe you
that you have adequate training and also
we're going to require that someone come
out and watch you do your procedure the
first time to verify that in fact you do
have the required training so I do think
that that that approach is just maybe a
little bit friendlier to the research
staff and and maybe a little more work
on that part of the I cook and that
brings me to my last bullet point on
here which is what do you do when dr.
Smith calls you up and says i just
bought a whole bunch of alligators and I
need to get blood from them next week
can you come over and show me how to do
that so this is what makes being a lab
animal trainer both pretty fun and also
pretty challenging at the same time
obviously the easy answer to that
question would be no I can't come help
you I have no idea where you might get
alligator blood from nor have I ever
touched one before but of course that
answer does not really meet the spirit
of our regulations which say that as a
facility we're going to provide training
to researchers to ensure that they're
able to humanely work with their animals
and it's important to remember that as a
person who works for a laboratory animal
department that you have probably many
more resources and connections than any
individual p I is going to have and you
need to use those connections to help
them as best you can with
you're weird training requests no matter
how strange they are so that might mean
that the trainer gets to go out and
learn something new and bring it home or
it might mean that trainer has to find a
place that the P I can travel to to
learn a procedure or bring a consultant
but any rate you need to make your best
effort to satisfy even the weirdest of
training requests alright continuing on
with our technical topics is anesthesia
and analgesia and if you have enough
staff who need the same kind of training
in anesthesia and analgesia then
offering the class is a great idea the
way we do it is we have a half lecture
half hands-on class it is only geared
towards rodents because that's where our
biggest volume is and if someone is
working with another species then we
handle that as a one-on-one as needed
kind of a request and these are the
topics that we cover in the lecture half
which comes first then we move on to the
hands-on portion and have developed a
good workflow for how to make this part
move quite smoothly we start out by
weighing animals mixing up drugs
calculating and then injecting
anesthetics then we watch the mice very
closely while they fall asleep so that
we can observe them moving through the
different stages of anesthesia also we
can observe when they lose specific
reflexes and monitor parameters to
determine depth of anesthesia once they
have all become anesthetized then I
bring out several I supporting machines
I try and pick some that look a little
different from each other so not just
all of the same and they're completely
disassembled when I
mout so people taking the class can
actually put their hands on the machines
look up the hoses fill them up turn on
the oxygen and learn about how the gas
flows through the machine because I so
flooring training is really as much
about understanding that machine and how
to make the machine work even when you
have some kind of a problem than
anything else so once the machines are
assembled and they anesthetize mice with
ice flooring which gives them a chance
to go through the induction part again
and then also to to watch the recovery
phase and by the time that's finished
some of the animals that we injected
we're given very light doses and they're
already starting to wake up and so then
that's another opportunity to to monitor
anesthesia recovery and I'm going to
lump the next three technical topics
together as surgical training so our
next three items off alistor aseptic
surgical technique surgical training and
pre post procedural care and if you have
sufficient need to put together a class
for this I have a couple of suggestions
about how that might look because we
actually have two different ways that we
offer this the first is actually it's a
credit University class software through
our Animal Sciences Department and it is
comprehensive not only of the three
topics in the title of the slide but
also anesthesia and analgesia it's a
week-long it does include live animal
surgery which in this case is a very
hysterectomy and it's offered every
other time with a different species so
large animal users and small animal
users can choose the more appropriate
species for themselves and take it
either with rats or with sheep the
second method that we're going to be
doing I I'm going to call the everything
but surgery works
up so this will actually not include any
live animals at all it will just be done
with models and include aseptic
technique instruments suturing and
general surgical principles and then as
a follow-up to that workshop then the
trainer will go into the lab with the
researcher with their actual animals and
their actual surgical procedure so one
really nice thing about conducting it in
this way is that the trainer can
actually verify that the researcher took
the information from the workshop and
applied it correctly back to their own
workspace and also a reduction in the
number of animals that that are being
used because we are going to use animals
in just a demonstration all right and
that brings me to the last item on our
list of requirements which is regular
continuing education and for animal care
staff and this is something that can
certainly be done in any way imaginable
it can just be a supervisor walking
around and talking with their staff it
can be field trips it can be seminars it
can be hands-on workshops we do have a
regular siiii event for our staff every
other week here and that seems to work
well and I know a lot of other
facilities are using that same idea I
have just a list here of topics that are
are good ones for seas for animal care
staff I'm sure you guys probably could
add 20 or so more to this list but here
are some ideas and then finally I just
wanted to give you my contact
information and again make the offer
that I'm definitely happy to share with
you any materials that I have anything
that I talked about in the in the
presentation today and thank you very
much
joining me and now I will open up my Q&A
box and see if there's any questions
that I can answer for you right now okay
so how often do you require refresher
training so as I mentioned or I cook
does not require any of hands-on
training specifically so that's I've
never for that I'm its individual
one-on-one basis the basic module that's
the online one showing all the all the
basic items that one's every three years
and the reason that three years was
selected is because we are protocols
could potentially last for three years
so that really is where that time flame
came from next question how much if any
of your course work is available to
anyone online outside of your
institution so none of it the online the
training database only allows you access
if you have a CSU ID so I would be happy
to share with you the powerpoints I
would have to just read acts like the
CSU specific information but they're not
available to the general public alright
next question with euthanasia training
are you utilizing a model for cervical
cervical dislocation or euthanizing an
animal per person per class so for us we
are mice that we use for training are
all donated they're mostly calls from
transgenic breeding colonies that don't
have the right genetics and so they're
going to be euthanized anyway and we
honestly have more than we can use and
so I do use an eyes an animal at least
one animal per person per class rather
than using a model just for the fact
that those animals are already readily
available
they're going to be euthanized anyway so
there there isn't really a need for us
to look for an alternative their next
question how do you respond to pee is
that suggests that the surgical
anesthetic trading is to intensive time
consuming or do you have this complaint
um so as I mentioned are our hands-on
training is not required necessarily by
the I cook and I have found that with
this more voluntary training that people
are always there because they want to be
and not because they're made to be and
so I guess I'm kind of lucky and that I
don't have that I don't have that
complaint where people are complaining
that they have are being forced to take
training they don't want so I don't have
a I don't think i have like a really
good answer to that one all right what
regime of anesthesia do you use in your
classes for mice and rats so the way
that I determined what anesthetics to
focus on in the class was I pulled all
of our protocols and I ran a report on
all the anesthetics that are in there
and i found out that with very very few
exceptions it was a really small list
and I'm so I just focus on those
particular drugs which are ketamine
xylazine acepromazine phenobarbital
dexmedetomidine and I so fine so we talk
will briefly about the fact that there's
all these other drugs out there and chat
with our veterinarians if you need to
find an alternative but in the class we
focus just on the primary ones that we
are actually being used at our
facilities do you train undergraduate
students with your surgical training
program or is this saved for grad and
postdocs it's available to anybody who's
going to be involved with research
surgery and so
definitely does include undergraduate
students although to a lesser extent
next one says wonderful presentation
thank you um do you deal with P is who
are MDS and if you do do they fall the
same and then I don't see the rest of
the question okay so here CSU I don't
deal with MDS very much because we don't
have a medical school we have a
veterinary school in a previous job I
did work with a lot of MDS so I can see
why maybe where this question is coming
from they don't always have as good of
additive attitudes about being turning
them on veterinary procedures but yeah
no we don't we don't have very many MDS
that we're working with here how many
student to trainer ratio detail for your
classes does it depend on the kind of
class so for the hands-on classes I
prefer to have one instructor for every
three students if at all possible
because if you have more students /
instructor than that the class just like
grinds to a halt because there's going
to be people who just stand there until
your next to them holding their hand so
I try very hard to have that three to
one ratio all right I think that is all
of our questions unless some new ones
come in no okay so it looks like that
concludes my presentation today thank
you everyone very much for attending